and welcome to the Bayesian optimization
talk where we will be talking about the
fundamentals how to implement and use
Bayesian optimization in practice
um we already covered my introduction I
guess so let's not worry about that here
but you can
um find me on the internet using the
links below especially in the middle if
you go to the GitHub repo you can find
these slides to the talk as well as some
other references
um so with that let's get started
talking about Bayesian optimization are
based off as we usually shorten it to
which is a machine learning technique
for optimizing Black Box functions so
here's the agenda for the next um 30
minutes
we were first talking about we will
first talk about the problem we're
trying to solve what black box
optimization is what motivates us to
solve this problem and then we're
talking we'll be talking about base off
which is the solution for black box
optimization
since this is by data we will also talk
about how to implement base up in
practice using state-of-the-art
libraries in Python and finally if time
permits we will talk about some slightly
specialized scenarios for optimization
using based out okay so what is black
box optimization it is a optimization
problem where we want to optimize for a
function an input any input output
process f of x that is we want to find
the input X that maximizes the value of
f of x and because of that we usually
call f of x the objective function
um there are several challenges to this
problem the first is that as the name
suggests f of x is a black box so we
cannot really look inside f of x we
don't know what it looks like we can
only get to observe the function values
y equals f of x at the input that you
choose so you can choose the input X and
you get to observe f of x but you don't
actually know the functional form of f
of x
the Second Challenge you might face is
evaluating the objective function so
Computing f of x is expensive either in
terms of time or money or some other
safety critical conditions this means
that you cannot really evaluate f of x
for too many times you only get to
evaluate it for a limited number of
times
so the goal in black box optimization is
to take strategically pick out input X
to evaluate the objective function with
in order to as quickly as possible find
the global Optimum of the objective
function
so this is a bit abstract let's consider
some examples
where a very common example is hyper
parameter tuning in machine learning so
a hyper parameter of an ml model is some
parameter that um
controls how the model learns or behaves
and cannot be learned from data so some
example could be the tree dust or the
number of leaves in a decision tree are
more common nowadays is the architecture
of a neural net so for example how many
layers your neural net has or how many
nodes your neural net has those are
hyper parameters
as you can imagine hyper parameters
control the behavior of your models and
in Black Box in hyperbole tuning you
want to pick the values for these hyper
parameters to best optimize some
objective that you have such as accuracy
on some validation test fat validation
set so here the objective function is
the validation accuracy and the input X
is the values for these hyper parameters
so again f of x is a black box so we
don't know how the validation accuracy
behaves with respect to the hyperable
parameters otherwise we would just you
know set it set the helper parameters
very easily but also evaluating the
objective function function so
Computing the validation accuracy is
very time consuming because you would
have to retrain the model with different
hyper parameters and evaluate it on the
validation set
um if you're working on your a very
large neural net that could be very
expensive
another
um example of black box optimization is
in product recommendation where a
recommendation system tries to find
products that a customer is looking for
so the objective function for this
recommendation system is the customers
preference and the input for this
objective function X is whatever product
we can recommend to the user again we
don't know the objective function is the
black boss we don't know how each
customer will react to each product we
recommend to them and also evaluating
the objective function is expensive so
we don't want to bombard the user with
too many recommendations right
and the goal is to optimize the
customer's preference find the product
that the customer likes the most
but black box optimization is not
limited to what tech company tech
companies do either if you are a
scientist say you might care about
scientific discoveries such as drug
Discovery here you want to find the
drugs that are most effective against
some disease so here the objective
function is Effectiveness against the
target disease and the input is the drug
that you are experimenting with and
synthesizing again objective function is
a black box you don't know how effective
each drop is until you actually test it
out but that testing process is also
expensive
it requires a lot of scientific
equipment and also a lot of money so
again um in black box optimization we
want to optimize for some black box
objective function but there are several
several challenges in our way that
require requires to have to pick out
intelligent locations to evaluate the
objective function with in order to as
quickly as possible to find the optimum
all right
let's stick with the example of hyper
parameter tuning for now and let's say a
goal here is in general to find the
architecture of the neural network to
maximize validation accuracy so we want
to find the number of nodes the network
has in order to maximize that validation
accuracy unless for example pretend that
the ground truth is something like this
where the x-axis is the number of notes
you can choose to implement a neural
network with and the accuracy on the
validation set behaves like this red
curve over here but remember in black
box optimization we don't get to know
how this objective function behaves we
don't know how the accuracy behaves so
we don't actually get to look at the red
curve we just saw
again what we have to do is to kind of
probe around within our Subspace which
is the x-axis probe around the objective
function to find to learn about the
objective function and find the global
Optimum
now this sounds like a pretty common
um task in machine learning engineering
so a popular machine learning library
such as scikit-learn should have some
pretty good automated solution for us
and it does in the model selection
module you have these different
solutions which basically boil down to
two separate strategies the first is
grid search and the second is random
search
so what grid search you basically divide
your search space the x-axis into equal
segments and then evaluate the objective
function at those grid points a
so here in this specific example the
best point that grid search finds is
that point on the right where the
validation accuracy is almost 80 percent
so it's it it does okay but what about
random search well because it's random
there's really no way for us to tell how
well it does but here's one example
where I basically set the random C to
zero and then draw random samples from
numpy
um here random search those What's Done
grid search even achieving the best
accuracy of roughly 60 that's is not
great and what we might also notice is
that it weighs a lot of function
evaluations around the left hand side
which doesn't really give any doesn't
give high accuracy so our takeaway is
exactly the title of this slide as well
uh naive strategies such as grid search
or random search mic waste valuable
resources that are functional
evaluations resources that we really
want to be very frugal about because
remember function evaluations are very
expensive so what we really want to do
is to carefully reason about what we
know and what we don't know about the
objective function from our limited data
and then picked out
um
the next function evaluation to best
find the global Optimum right and that's
exactly what place app does for us on
the right hand side I'm showing the
result of base of where the number
numbers denote the order in which the
function evaluations are made by based
off so it based off chooses the function
evaluations that we see here
um you can see in the beginning it kind
of
spreads out its function evaluations
throughout the space but then quickly
Narrows down to the region that contains
the global Optimum so this is very nice
to see
um so how does based off exactly do this
based off um involves an optimization
Loop where we start out with a machine
learning model that is the gaussian
process that runs from past function
evaluations and make predictions about
the objective function now this gaussian
process the machine learning model has
uncertainty Quantified quantification
which is very important for decision
making later on and we will get to this
very soon so don't worry if you don't
know what incentive quantification is
anyway so these predictions will inform
our decisions specifically a
decision-making policy that will help us
find the next point to evaluate the
objective function with in order to find
the global Optimum
so the job of this decision making
policy is to generate a score that
quantifies how valuable each potential
new data point is in terms of helping us
find the next um find the global Optimum
of the function and we usually visualize
the score as the screen curve over here
so again the higher the score is the
more valuable that data point is in
terms of helping us find the global
Optimum so it's so our job would be to
generate the score with the help of the
decision making policy and then pick out
the data point that has the highest
score
which is this star over here and then
evaluate the objective function at that
point and add that to our training data
set that contains all the function
evaluations that we have made and then
use this newly updated data set to train
the machine learning model at step one
and repeat everything all over again
until we cannot evaluate the objective
functions anymore
so this is the overarching based upload
and
will be going into the different
um components
uh starting now
so what is the gaussian process that we
use as the predictive model in base opt
and let's pretend that we are working
with this specific training data where
we have one two three four five data
points that are function observation
observations from the objective function
now we first note that common machine
learning models such as a decision tree
say or a neural net only produce single
value predictions and what do I mean by
this
um here I'm showing the prediction as
the blue curve of a rich regression
model trained on the five trending data
points we see here as black axis and
what we notice again is that it only
produced this single value predictions
in a sense that oh if you want to know
the prediction at this point 200 then
it's just this one number here
if you want to know the prediction at
this point 400 it's just this number
here so it's just one single number for
each prediction
and because of that there's no
quantification of uncertainty and but by
quantification of uncertainty I mean
something like this let's say we care
about how confident we are about the
prediction in this region over here
between
um two trending data points that are
very close by to each other here and
here
intuitively you should be thinking that
um any prediction in this region should
be very soon we should discern about
these predictions because there's not a
lot of wiggle room for the objective
function right between these two data
points well maybe in this region over
here at 200 we should be very uncertain
about our prediction just because it's
not very close to any of our training
data points so there's a lot of wiggle
room for the objective function to
change so we should be very uncertain
over here but again with this Rich
regression model or an
or other common ml models you only have
one single number as your prediction and
that's not quite good because again we
want in base off we want to reason about
what we know and what we don't know
about the objective function so there's
a need for quantifying uncertainty
um sorry about that
and that's exactly what a gaussian
process does for us each the prediction
of a gaussian process at each data point
is a normal distribution and we usually
visualize the predictions uh like this
where the blue curve is the mean
prediction and the Shaded region is the
arrow bars of the normal distributions
somewhat specific more specifically
right let's just consider a prediction
at 200 again
a 200 the
um the mean function the blue Curve will
give us the mean of the normal
distribution mu and the boundaries of
the Shaded region the arrow bars will
give us two standard roughly two
standard deviations away from the mean
and using this mu and this Sigma the
mean and the standard deviation we have
a normal distribution representing our
prediction at this point 200.
but not just 200 right we have a normal
distribution at every given data point
within our search space and each of that
each of the predictions is a normal
distribution and what's nice about the
normal distribution is that the spread
of the distribution quantifies our
uncertainty about that pre-production
so let's say here in this region we see
that the normal distribution of
prediction is very concentrated which
means that we are very certain about a
prediction over here while over here 200
again the normal distribution is very
spread out so we are very uncertain in
this region which is exactly what we
want
so by using gaussian process we get this
quantification of uncertainty which
again is very important for decision
making because we have to reason about
what we know and what we don't know
about the objective function
okay
speaking of decision making a key
component of decision making is the
exploitation exploration trade-off and
roughly speaking you can think of that
as sticking to what we know versus
taking a risk so we have to choose
between these two actions
let's consider this example again
now looking at um
the training data we have and the
predictions made by the gaussian process
let's try to think about
um what where we should evaluate the
objective function next in order to
optimize it right well you might think
you want to focus on this region because
um a prediction at that region is very
high it gives high value and that would
correspond to exportation we are
exploiting the our knowledge about the
the objective function to optimize it
well but you might also say hey around
these regions we don't know too much
about the objective function or
uncertainty is high so me we might want
to explore these regions corresponding
to exploration we might want to explore
these regions to learn about the
objective function more well in this
specific example it's quite clear to us
that exploitation is what we want to do
because we can look at the objective the
real ground true of rejected function
but that's not always the case
in another scenario if our training data
set is something like this then
exploitation would be corresponding to
query
evaluating the objective function around
this region which can get us stuck to
this local Optimum so it's actually not
the best optimum right the best optimum
is over here well exploration on the
other hand will help you learn about the
the objective function more and
hopefully uncover the true Global
Optimum so
a very an intelligent balance between
exploitation and exploration is key to
decision making is key to any base of
policy that we design
and I usually think of this trade-off as
ordering from a restaurant where
exploitation right would be um would be
ordering something that you know you
would like well exploration would be
corresponding to ordering something that
you don't know anything about and the
goal is still to find the item that you
like best from this menu but you have to
balance between
sticking to what you know and taking a
risk again okay so how does a base op
policy actually do this
it and we will be sticking to this um
example throughout
so with the base of policy you have to
use a decision-making heuristic and one
heuristic could be to pick the input X
that will improve from the best point
that we have seen so far the most in
this trending set the point that the
best point that we have seen so far is
this point over here that gives the
highest objective value that we have
seen throughout and that corresponds to
this dotted line so that this dotted
line is f Star as we are denoting here
week one again to maximize the
Improvement that we will have by uh by
evaluating f of x for some X from F Star
right so we want to maximize this
quantity here that quantifies the
Improvement
and that corresponds to the
green shaded region
now the problem is always we don't know
f of x is so um
we don't we don't get to decide we don't
get to decide which one will give us the
most possible Improvement but from the
gaussian process we know that each f of
x follows a normal distribution and
because the normal distribution is a
very nice mathematical object it allows
us to compute the average value of this
Improvement quantity over here according
to the normal distribution
so this is the expected value of this
quantity we usually call it the expected
Improvement quantity and this expected
Improvement quantity is the score that
we will use to basically rank the
different data points that we can use as
input to evaluate the objective function
next to
um to find the global Optimum
so once again the score quantifies how
valuable each data point is in the
search for the global Optimum and this
call balances between exploitation
exploration as well if um if a data
point has a very large prediction mean
then it will also in it will increase
the expected Improvement score and that
will correspond to exploitation like
this region over here
if a point has a very large standard
deviation so high uncertainty that will
also increase our expected Improvement
score corresponding to these regions
over here
expiration so this policy this expected
Improvement score balances between
exploitation exploration just like we
like to be
and once again what we would want to do
is to pick out the data point that has
the highest score and that would be the
point that we choose to evaluate the
objective function next
and that will complete one iteration of
the Bayesian optimization Loop
sorry again
um but remember in the loop we would
repeat everything all over again until
we run out of function evaluations right
so here I'm showing an animation showing
the evolution of base of that we saw in
the beginning where it sequentially
picks out the next point to query the
objective function next using the
expected Improvement score that we just
saw
um several things
um we can notice from this first this
policy leverages past observations to
inform feature decisions and by doing
that it doesn't get stuck at a local
Optimum over here which is exactly what
we want but it also doesn't explore low
performing regions either so it kind of
ignores this region over here where the
accuracy is low so that's also very nice
and because of that we are able to
converge to a global Optimum easily So
based off is very successful in this
specific test
um but remember seeking to improve from
the best point that we have seen so far
is only a heuristic and by choosing
different optimization heuristics we can
obtain different base art policies
different ways of making decisions
um very popular heuristics are drawn
from the multi-unbedded problem from
reinforcement learning one of them is
the upper confidence bound on UCB policy
and this one basically you in this one
you basically use the
um upper region of the arrow bar in your
prediction as the score that quantifies
how valuable your data points are so
this green curve on the bottom is
matches exactly what the screenshot at
the top
um which is one way to make decisions
right another way to make decisions is
content sampling which involves drawing
samples from the gaussian process
people consider a gaussian process as a
distribution over functions and because
it's a distribution you can draw samples
from it
and you for each sample you pick out the
data point that maximizes that sample
and that will be the next point that you
use to evaluate the objective function
but
all right another way to make decisions
is to leverage information Theory and
that would be to
minimize your uncertainty about the
location of the objective function the
the location of the global Optimum the
objective function and that will
correspond to correspond to entropy
search policies
and each of the policies we just talked
about balances between exploitation and
exploration in its own way but
unfortunately there's no
one-size-fits-all policy that will work
well across all problems so it requires
a little bit of trial and error to find
which policy works well in your problem
all right so that is the background for
base off let me just quickly mention
some success stories for base art
um I've mentioned hyper parameter tuning
that's a study
um
there's a study research study that
found that based off is very successful
at um hyper perennial tuning so they
have conclusive evidence for this which
is nice to see you can also use base off
again for scientific discovery just to
such as to discover enzymes or molecules
which I think is quite cool
all right so that is based off how can
we Implement based off using python
luckily for us there's a cohesive
software ecosystem that we can use that
starts with pie torch for tensor
manipulation
be python to implement Russian processes
so that predictive machine learning
model we use and finally BOTOX for
implementing based our policies
now with G pytos to implement gaussian
processes you basically need two
components the first is a mean function
and the second is Kernel I'm gonna cross
over some details over here because I
think I'm running out of time but base
GPI touch makes it very easy to
implement a gaussian process model and
the API almost resembles the API to
implement a neural net in Python so if
you have some experience working with
pytosh G python could be very easy to do
and gpatosh um
it offers a wide range of main functions
and kernels so by combining different
mean functions in kernels you can model
a wide range of um patterns wide range
of behaviors for your objective function
all right what about Botox botosh is
used to implement based our policies and
because it's very modular sometimes
changing the policy that we are using is
equivalent to just replacing one line of
code
most of the time so let's let's say you
want to use expected Improvement then
you can you can just use this line of
code to implement the policy if you want
to use UCB instead you could simply swap
out that line of code for this line of
code very easy to do Thomson sampling is
a little bit more complicated but once
again both charge messages makes it very
easy to do
all right
um
there are specialized settings in the
real world where you um don't have that
very simple structure of evaluating the
objective function once this location
and then add that to your training data
and repeat sometimes you have more
specialized scenarios
for example in batch optimization you
might be able to make multiple
evaluations at the same time this is
very common in hyper parameter tuning
right you might be able to train
multiple models on a cluster of gpusa so
you are able to make multiple
evaluations at the same time
you might have constraint optimization
where you have to satisfy some
constraints while optimizing for the
objective function this is common in
product recommendation where you want to
present products to a user while keeping
the cost of that product below sometimes
threshold so you don't want to suggest
very expensive item to your user
multi-objective function optimizations
also very popular where you have to
contend with multiple potentially
competing objectives one example I like
to use is in hyper parameter tuning
again where not only you want to
optimize for accuracy on a validation
set but you might want to optimize for
also training time the size of the model
so you want to keep the model small so
that it's efficient to run
luckily for US based office and is able
to handle all of these different
scenarios but we won't be going through
that here
all right so as the last note I want to
mention that been working on this book
called Bayesian optimization in action
with many and basically a more detailed
version of this talk where I I try to
use a lot of plots to visualize
different mathematical Concepts
in this book which I think would help
with the learning process you are Pi
data so you can use this code or the QR
code below to obtain a 35 discount code
for any mailing books including mine and
you can also contact me uh for a free
ebook copy
um which I have three uses alrighty
thanks for your attention and I'll be
very happy to take any questions perhaps
we're running low on time so we can move
the conversation to to Discord